[موسيقى]
بسخريته المعتاده من خصومه شن الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب هجوما عنيفا
على حاكم فلوريدا سانتوس
في ولايه ايوا حاول خلاله ابطاء صعود نجم
ديستانتاس منافسه الرئيسي المحتمل في
الحزب الجمهوري الذي زار المدينه قبل ايام
الاستطلاع يقول ان ترامب لا يزال يتمتع
بمعدلات موافقه عاليه في قاعده الناخبين
الجمهوريين ويتفوق على الرونديس في
استطلاع تلو الاخر وانا اتغلب على جو بايد
كثيرا وهذا مهم جدا
وقبل ذلك صرح ترامب لصحافيين على متن
طائرته بانه ندم على تاييد
بانه غير مخلص وبانه كان ميتا كالكلب
مضيفا بان حياته السياسيه كانت ستنتهي لو
لم يؤيد حملته عام 2018
من الحصول على اي زخم انتخابيه والبدء
بزياده عدد مؤيديه لذلك يريد ايقافه قبل
ان يبدا
وبشان تصريحاتنا ابي الرئيس السابق مايك
بانس بان التاريخ سيحاسب ترامب على هجوم
الكابيتول اعتبر ترامب بان بانس كان
مسؤولا عن اعمال العنف في السادس من يناير
عام 2021
كان من اللافته ان ترامب لم يهاجم بانس
بالحده ذاتها التي هاجم فيها رغم ان الاول
انتقده والثاني يتجاهله حتى الان وهو ما
يراه البعض مؤشرا على مخاوف ترامب بشان
حاكم فلوريدا الذي ينظر اليه على انه اخطر
منافسيه حسين الطاوضه العربيه واشنطن